Kanye has a new song this is his first
song ever since the uh eccentric shall
we say uh display that he made like what
was it about a year ago on the Alex
Jones Show and with the face mask and
the the yah the net and yah yooo and
where he was going after the Jews and
all that you remember that thing so
anyway he's got a new song out here is
the
song with all I don't know night I got
and know I didn't put that drop in there
that drop is in the record
[Music]
already baby
is baby is
it okay you know I think this will be
more actually productive if I just read
the lyrics
this not I don't look I'm not really
even
knocking I am knocking the music I guess
but it's it's not for me this is not I'm
not I'm not a big fan of hip-hop or rap
or most music made in the last 70 or 80
years uh I've liked some of Kanye's
music in the past I like that song that
he wrote with Paul McCartney only one I
thought that was pretty good I've often
thought Kanye is a pretty good uh has a
pretty good ear so he hears good songs
that he then samples and wraps over and
I don't love the rapping but I you know
like Jesus Walks is a great example
that's s Jesus walk you know and then
that's a good song and then he wraps
over it and makes it popular so okay uh
this song is with um Ty doign and l
Durk whoever they are and here are the
lyrics Three gang leaders with me all
times I don't know who I effed last
night I got Alzheimer's I don't know who
them hos is man they all Li and Brody
tell me who them hos is man they all
fine run and Hol again and we with the
foolishness how how I'm anti-semitic I
just effed a Jewish I just effed
scooter Brawn the the big celebrity
manager B and we ran up like Olympics
got pregnant in the threesome whose baby
is it whose baby is it my ninjas he
doesn't say ninjas but it's a word that
I'm not allowed to say because I'm a
white fellow uh Puttin belt to a s pull
up with the switches this ain't Jimmy
Butler but the heat got extensions this
ain't Coline but we came in with the
trenches I assume trench coat she asking
me to aim for this is a this is a little
toddy this lyric more so even than the
others she asking me to aim for her neck
cuz her boyfriend bought that necklace
with the trenches presses with the
trenches eff it I scratched another
ninja woman up off my checklist okay why
do I read any of this right now text Nes
to 9898 98 we are facing the threat of a
potential government shutdown and the
administration will ultimately deal with
it the same way they always do with more
spending more spending will inevitably
devalue the dollar protect your savings
by diversifying into gold with the help
of B Birch gold group when you open an
IRA with Birch gold for every $10,000
you spend by December 22nd Birch gold
will send you a free gold bar just text
n canw to 998 9898 to claim eligibility
before Black Friday Birch gold can even
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold without taking any
money out of pocket are you still
listening because you get a free gold
bar it's a big deal with an A+ rating
with a Better Business Bureau and
thousands of satisfied customers you can
count on Birch gold to help you
transition an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold don't let your savings
fall victim to the further devaluation
of the dollar text nolles canids to 98
9898 receive a free info kit on gold and
claim your eligibility before Black
Friday to receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles kW to
9898 right now go to pre- born.com we
talk about pre-born a lot on this show
it's because we believe in their mission
and we know that you do too who would
not want to help mothers and their
children in crisis pre-born is an
organization dedicated to saving the
lives of The Unborn every day pre-born
network of clinics rescues 200 babies as
they compete head-to-head with the
abortion Giants they offer free
ultrasounds to mothers considering
abortion and once she sees her baby and
hears its heartbeat she is twice as
likely to choose life it it basically
doubles the baby's chance at surviving
and right now through a matching program
your tax dedu gift is itself doubled
100% of your gift will go toward
providing free ultrasounds to mothers in
crisis as well as supporting mothers and
their babies with diapers car seats
counseling and more Now's the Time of
the Year everyone's writing their checks
it's time to get the write off so I
usually wait until New Year's Eve don't
be like me do it now double down today
by dialing pound 250 say the keyword
baby that is pound 250 or go to pre-born
preborn docomo
wle
this is a song about
revenge Kanye is singing There's there
are other verses with other rappers in
it but this is his verse and he's
singing about revenge I don't know who I
effed I got Alzheimer's you can't say
that I don't like Jews I just effed one
of those Jews and I just effed this
other guy's girlfriend and I just I I
disrespected him and a gift that he had
given her yeah I'm just it's not even
about her it's about him and I'm just
getting back at him and I'm getting back
at scoter braa and I'm getting back at
the Jews and I'm getting back at this
guy and I'm getting back at that guy and
I'm just effing everybody and I'm
hitting people and I'm I'm like I'm like
the shooters at Coline I'm dressing up
in trench coats like them it's all about
revenge and it's about revenge
presumably because Kanye got
canel and he lost a ton of money and
Adidas canceled him and he he'll
probably bounce back to some degree
because the guy just seems to be made of
Teflon even after his uh rather
elaborate breakdown last year but it's
the Revenge to me that's the key because
he made another album not that long ago
called Jesus's King that was actually
somewhat Beautiful by the standards of
modern pop music I think there was a
song on there water we are water like a
newborn daughter and um a friend of mine
actually wrote part of the bridge to
that song actually ironically my a
Jewish friend of mine wrote part of the
bridge to that song but the whole album
was just about how Jesus is King and we
should all be Christian and worship God
and be good and uh rumored during the
making of that album was Kanye's and
that nobody engage in fornication and he
was trying to save his marriage and a
lot of people go crazy after a divorce
and but he he really seemed to be aiming
at virtue and then here in this new song
as first we've heard from him in in over
a year or about a year at
least it's all just about getting back
at people and doing nasty things and
fornicating and hitting people and you
know and vengeance is mine sayeth the
Lord and I will repay and and so I I
feel for
guy in that it's very easy to to fall
into Vice and to to enjoy the notion of
revenge against people you think have
wronged you but
it's not the right way if you compare
this song to The Jesus's King album
Jesus's King album is much better and
Kanye was probably in a much better
place when he was doing that album what
a great clip that was now hey whoa whoa
whoa ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel see you next
time